All right.
Let's get right into audience questions for
the week.
I understand what is on people's minds and
that explains why these are the questions
I've gotten.
First one is, hey, David, what is the longest
that the United States can realistically stay
shut down because of coronavirus?
So I'm going to answer the question as asked.
But please understand that we never really
shut down to the degree that Europe did.
And when you look at, you know, 4.8 percent
GDP decline in Q1, that's that's a lot.
That's crazy.
But that's an economy that's mostly still
open now.
OK.
The shutdowns didn't start until March.
If we have a 20 percent decline in Q2, April,
May, June.
That is crazy.
That's a crazy.
But consider that that still means 80 percent
of the economy is still up and running.
So compared to Europe, the United States restrictions
have been really light.
The stay home orders have been put in place
in a number of states.
Essential stores are still open for the most
part.
You know, all grocery stores, hardware stores
in Massachusetts, restaurants remained open
for takeout.
People could go around not wearing masks outdoors
and even indoors for a long time.
You could go wherever you want.
Parks were open.
Some places have had to close parks because
of people gathering.
A lot of beaches remained open as long as
people weren't on top of each other in Italy.
Just this week, people started to be allowed
to go more than 200 meters from their house
or fight.
I think in Spain it was 500 meters.
We never had that in the United States, even
in the strictest situations.
Wherever.
I don't know if we would consider Michigan
to have been the strictest or whatnot, but
we were never really fully shut down.
And a lot of what we saw in the U.S. is really
a city vs. suburban suburb rural distinction
because I've been in Boston, restaurants remained
open for takeout.
But the streets are quite empty.
There's like very little traffic going
places.
So certainly the more urban areas of the city
seem noticeably empty, but a lot of the basics
stayed open the entire time.
Suburbs may not even have been as dramatically
different.
It's hard for me to say for sure.
So the answer is in terms of how much longer
can we stay, quote, shut down.
It's very clear that there is not a lot of
political appetite, even in the more liberal
states, to stay shut.
Even a single data longer than public health
officials say that we should.
So I think we're increasingly going to start
seeing two tiers.
We're going to start to see places that had
early hotspots and took it very seriously.
New York and Massachusetts and California
are the ones I'm most familiar with, that
in the next two weeks to four weeks, two to
three weeks are going to be able to
start opening some things with caution, still
with masks indoors, outdoors, where when you
can't social distance.
But there will be some opening up.
More than likely, manufacturing hopefully
can start to come back with people wearing
masks and distancing in of factories, et cetera.
The governors will sort of figure it out.
The problem is that we are starting to see
rapidly rising cases in places like Florida,
Georgia, Texas.
And there are others, although I don't have
the numbers readily, sort of in my mind and
on a percentage basis, they are seeing faster
and faster increases in cases.
They're not going to be able to open up or
if they do, it is going to be significantly
tragic, significantly tragic.
So you have some states starting to say we're
going to start running out of unemployment
insurance money.
That's going to be pressure, especially for
Republican governors
who are very concerned with the debt in this
abstract sense to try to open up the saddest
part about all of it.
And ultimately, these are decisions that governors
will have to make.
And the answer is many of them are going to
start opening some things in the next two
to three weeks.
Sadly, if on March 5th, when we had over 200
cases, Trump had said from the federal government,
I need all 50 governors to do a shelter in
place, stay at home.
After we had done that on March 5th, we would
be in really good shape right now.
That's what we're seeing in other countries.
South Korea took care of things despite having
their first case at the same time we did.
And that is that is the really lost opportunity,
that there is no way to go back and undo at
this point
in time.